a type of movie theater not seen in  decades is now open  downtown the venue only shows movies on  film  nothing is digital in a nutshell it's  it's a product of age it's you know  it's nostalgia at its best it is called  the 35  cinema you can find it inside  neanopoulos it really is a trip back in  time  the projector right there in the  audience you watch staff  thread the film before the movie even  starts playing  and it is actually played on an actual  silver screen  all movies that you'll be watching were  released before the year 2000  now this weekend here's the films that  are playing you can catch the classic  alien another classic the shining  tickets  just 10 bucks kind of a step back in  cinematic history right here in las  vegas  a chance to see a movie maybe the way  they intended us to see it